as promised from the worldwide leader in
sports he will be on nfl live an hour
after we are done
four eastern on espn later on today
taking to kick off of the big monday
night finale between seattle
and philadelphia dan roloffsky here on
the rich eisen show how are you dan
rich i'm doing well it's a it's an honor
and a pleasure to be on with you man i
appreciate you saying that thank you
very much and i really
uh and have been enjoying your work on
espn
and uh definitely um uh appreciate your
your opinions on so many items uh first
up for bids is what we saw last night on
sunday night football with the bears
how in the world does chicago rectify
their quarterback position
in your estimation right now dan yeah i
think the bears as an organization are
probably looking at a complete
overhaul because ryan pace has got to be
responsible in some capacity
listen he built a lot of good pieces at
defense but he's also built this offense
in
the selection of mitchell trubisky and
then matt maggie is in many ways hand
picked
to not like he didn't pick mitch
trubisky but he was hand-picked to
develop mitchell trubisky
and we while milton you know mitchell
might not be
obviously desean and patrick he hasn't
gotten better
and so that has to be pegged on
management and coaching
that the lack of development at that
position has got to fall on their square
their shoulders and then for mitchell i
have said for
about almost two years now that i think
they use him
poorly i don't think they accentuate his
skill set that being said
the at the end of the day he's not good
enough
in 2020 with the quarterbacks the young
ones that we have in the nfl right now
mitchell is not going to be good enough
to carry your franchise forward and to
be a bona fide winner
and legit playoff contender and then
super bowl champion so
while he's athletic and has a skill set
and i do
think um hasn't been accentuated
at the end of the day they're gonna have
to move on from him i think it's likely
they move on from matt nagy from the
lack of development and lack of
leadership
and i think it's fair to say ryan pace
as the general manager and the guy that
hand-picked him
is going to be on the hot seat as well
yeah i know there was a shot uh
nbc's cameras caught pace uh in his mass
just shaking his head kind of was a
perfect
uh i guess um image of what's going on
with the bears and they were five and
one dan i mean there were five was that
all just smoke and mirrors and mirage i
mean
how does the team go five and one to
five and six like that
their defense was dominant and they were
winning games because of the defense and
so
you know that's kind of where i i always
get into it with people when people say
well defense wins championships in 2005
it did yes
that's not the case anymore because of
the rules and the understanding of space
and how much smarter offensive coaches
are
and the skill sets of so many different
people in the quarterback run game
that doesn't prove to be true anymore
and i thought
when they made the move to nick foles i
did not think that was the right choice
although i love nick
and i said okay well if nick just throws
the ball to the right
place they should be decent enough where
where their defense is gonna keep them
in
every game and then nick started to
really turn the ball over and that
offense started to slow down and then
that fares
it just puts such a big burden on the
defense and i think the defense is at
the point where where they're just
misses three years now this is three
years now of being a championship
caliber defense in chicago
and having to go out there and go if we
don't score as a defense and we give up
two touchdowns
we're probably gonna lose the game and
uh i think that that is just weighing so
heavily on their defense nfl veteran
quarterback now at the worldwide leader
in sports from espn dan orlovsky here on
the rich eisens show so you're saying
it'll be not one but
two teams cleaning house in the nfc
north because the lions did that over
the weekend
uh matt patricia and bob quinn are out
um and uh that led me to take to twitter
um
it essentially pounding the table for
something that i know it won't happen
but hire jim caldwell back and choose a
gm who knows him and go to work is what
i tweeted out and
i got to tell you man um you know i'm
used to getting twitter
trolls but it was more than just trolls
that hit me i i got
absolutely torched for this take i i
know you were there
in the jim caldwell era in detroit yeah
and and i
i think you've said the same exact thing
i might be i might be following in your
footsteps dan
so you you have the floor knowing the
organization as you do and knowing what
caldwell did there
um i'll give you the floor on this
subject
yeah i have i i sure a lot of the same
feelings as you with the situation and i
share the same feeling with jim caldwell
my overall overarching view would be
this
the lions organization have tried a lot
of different things
over the last i don't know 20 years
they've tried a lot of things
offensive-minded coaches defensive
minded coaches the hot coordinator all
the stuff
only one of them has worked only one
coach that they have hired has been
successful now maybe
maybe he hasn't climbed all the way to
the top of the mountain but only one guy
had the culture right
had the locker room right had the
expectations right
and had the team playing like every
single week
you believed all right the line this is
going to be a good game and if they play
the way they're capable of playing
they'll win that football game and it
was trending in the right direction they
had a quarterback in matthew stafford
in really the prime of his career
playing top five top six football and so
i sit back and he'll go
all right i know it is a rich no one
loves
smart offensive football more than me
i'm a complete nerd when it comes to
that stuff so i can understand people
going no you got to get your offensive
coach
really because everyone wants sean mcvay
listen
i was with sean he's a unicorn as great
as he is when it comes to his x's and
o's
he's a significantly better leader when
it comes to organizational
kind of galvanizing foresight all of the
things that are going to be needed to be
a great head coach
sean excels at and then he's also
remarkably good at with the yes
x's and o so i caution right now just to
go just find a really good offensive
coordinator no
the lions need somebody that knows that
organization
that knows the ins and outs of what
works and what doesn't
knows that city knows that communication
now if jim caldwell is available
and he wants that job and he tells you
this is my offensive coordinator i'm
going to bring
this guy as an offensive coordinator
he's got a couple of names on the list
and that offensive coordinator runs a
scheme or a style
and sees football the way it needs to be
seen right now in the nfl
then i think that it's very it's it's um
it's negligent to not sit down and go
someone's got to prove to me that
there's a better option than this
because i know
this guy can do it i know that he can
get us heading in the right place
the same way he did years ago so dan
i'll push back on the same stuff i got
pushed back
on uh one is that uh caldwell was
dreadful against teams with winning
records
uh you could count on uh one hand
apparently the number of times that a
winning record
uh team came in and lost to caldwell's
lions
and two uh that yeah uh maybe he was
eight games over 500 did uh
get a couple of wild card appearances
but it's about winning championships and
he wasn't even close to that
so that was the pushback i got okay so
i'll address the first one yes we we um
we beat
a lot of the kind of average teams and
below average teams
and we played with a lot of the good
teams and we were never able to get kind
of
over that hump well that's also because
he was still in building mode you know
they had just
and i would say this martin mayhew was a
guy as the next general manager
that probably got fired or moved on from
and and that was an incorrect move as
well because martin had started to get
some drafts going maybe he wasn't the
pittsburgh steelers when it comes to the
drafts but
he was starting to draft better and it
was really in lockstep that they were
doing things together and so
i always tell people this you know
during my first kind of go around with
the lines and people would ask
why were you guys so bad i said look at
our draft look at our first round picks
the first round picks were
missed after miss after miss so to kind
of build your organization and build
your program
to really start to become a team that
consistently beats the good teams
because again there's only like six of
them in the nfl
that takes time um so i i can understand
where people are coming from
but that's not something that usually
happens on a consistent basis within the
first three or four years
of a head coach's role as that in that
organization
and then i understand it's about
championships i i get all that
but find me the last coach that walked
in and just won a championship that just
walked in and goes okay first three
years i went i took a perennial basement
team over 20 years and i won a super
bowl with some like
the the the lions fans and their
organization have to realize
that this has to be stacked and stacked
and stacked and there is no quick fix
that
that's my point they've tried to have
the quick fix they've tried that
multiple times it doesn't work there
it's not gonna work there
dan orlowski here on the rich eisen show
uh
and i guess you can even just well
obviously
nobody has just aaron rodgers sitting
around but the whole narrative
of matt lafleur is going to have to
teach his
quarterback a system or the old leopard
is going to have to change his spots and
and aaron rodgers was grinding gears
with mike mccarthy and it was just not
going to work
well 13-3 last year and now we saw
the performance on sunday night why has
it worked for matt lafleur
in your estimation in green bay dan yeah
i think that it's worthy of us putting
him into the conversation of one of the
better coaches in football right now and
certainly uh
in the running for coach of the year i'd
say this
matt's got a great you know i was on the
set for get up with
with greeny the moment that matt lafleur
got the head coaching job
and i had had history with him in two
different places in houston and with the
rams
and i had said this is going to work out
perfectly and grainy looked at me like
who
matt lafleur what are you talking about
and i said the best thing is
matt lafleur will not back down from a
strong personality in aaron rodgers
they will he will continue to push him
and push back on him in a respectful
manner but in a challenging manner
and i think aaron's one of those players
we came into the the nfl the same year
together he's one of those players that
wants to be challenged he wants to be
intellectually challenged he wants to be
um
challenged with motivation he wants to
be
challenged with his ability to fully
grasp what the
what the plan is offensively and how to
attack certain defenses
and i think the biggest thing that
matt's done is clarify things for him
he's made some stuff easy you watch that
team it looks a lot like kansas city you
know patrick holmes is the greatest
talent i've ever seen
there's some stuff there in that offense
that is easy for him it gives them a
mental breather it gives them a physical
breather
and i think matt's done a really good
job with that in green bay
he knows what they're good at he knows
that aaron's great at outside the pocket
well why
because he can make throws on the move
that other guys can't it gives him the
opportunity to
create post snap a little bit more that
he can move in space a little bit more
and so
i think that he's got a really good feel
for what they're good at he doesn't
expose them to kind of the deficiencies
of their offense
um he uses devante brilliantly and i
think the big thing is just
understanding that aaron wanted to
he wanted a coach that was going to
bring him
greatness like they give him the
opportunity to be great again
and that's why it's working so well in
green bay so then why isn't it working
in
in tampa i guess dan dan orolovsky from
espn here
on the rich eisen show i mean you just
mentioned how uh mahomes has some easy
things we talk about how elaborate that
that scheme is in kansas city but they
also give some easy things it also helps
to give
uh tyree kill uh one-on-one coverage as
we saw
um tampa bay continuously do in that
first quarter yesterday
but it just it was jarring to me again
uh dan to see brady in the role of can
he keep peace with the other team's
offense
that's been the narrative for brady on
the other
foot for 20 years um but they
they they lost that game in the first
quarter it was essentially done right
there
what is going on there and how can it be
fixed to make brady
maybe more comfortable on that offense
the last few weeks
yeah the best way i can describe tampa
bay right now is
they are so dependent on an incredibly
high level and really an
unreal realistic level of execution like
if they get 70 snaps
and they have to be so good all 11
across the board with their execution
that it just challenges their offense
and
and kind of minimizes their level of
success because i think there's two
things
in the nfl that has really started to
show us up a little bit on the back end
of last year
and then it's been dominant this year
that are our difference makers for
the really good offenses in the nfl
pre-snap motion
and i'm not just talking about one guy
going from one side of the formation to
the other
i'm talking like with speed and snapping
the ball at the same time because it
creates leverage
and angles for blocking and matchups and
gives defenses a ton to look at so
you have to do that and then you have to
utilize
play action pass and the buccaneers
don't do either of that
and so those things really minimize the
necessity or the need
for a high level of execution because
you're like oh well i already got
i got you out in space versus a
linebacker great you don't need to be
great you just need to be good enough
and so that's why when i mention like it
minimizes the need for this high level
of execution when you do that stuff
and the buccaneers don't and so they're
just so demanding
on everybody on their offense to be just
at their absolute best
all the time and that's just really bad
coaching and they're do they're not
doing things that tom brady is so
kind of notorious for gets a line of
scrimmage gronkowski's out there
oh there's a corner now i know it's zone
okay now i've
i've cut half of my thinking or half the
time that it needs that i need to think
i've cut in half and so
um i think that bruce arians is and
byron leprech are just stuck in their
ways
because they've seen it work before no
i've seen this work
with carson palmer or andrew luck or big
ben i know this offense is good well
that might be true
but it's not good right now it's you
have different people operating it and
they
maxim or they kind of expose themselves
to way too many of their weaknesses
offensively their protection
the deep ball it happens way too much
the question can it be fixed
how they got 12 practices left you know
like they got
if it hasn't been fixed or altered since
august
it's hard for me to think that over the
next four or five weeks that they're
gonna remarkably or
miraculously change who they are last
one for you dan before i send you to the
set of nfl live and you're taking
everybody to kick off um
a part of the coverage of the worldwide
leader in sports taking a kick off of
monday night football between seattle
and philadelphia after philadelphia lost
its last game
uh dan the question was once again put
doug peterson about his quarterback
carson wentz being the starter and he
basically said he's the starter and said
if he turned to jalen hurts
uh that it would indicate to the team
that the season is over
and then a few days later when asked if
uh carson was
uh you know he was still a starter he
said i would think so
now we're hearing hertz took some snaps
with the ones over the weekend
what do you expect to see tonight for
philadelphia uh as
both the washington football team and
giants have already won
this week yeah i i think that carson
once will take the great majority of the
snaps in this football game he'll be the
starter
i would expect um jalen hurts to be used
in two specific areas which is something
that probably should have been happening
more
one third down and let's say under four
yards
you know very situationally specific
where you can utilize
11 on 11 football you can kind of add in
quarterback run
um and maybe potentially some rpos to
allow guys out in space so i think
that'll be a little bit more because
this team has been bad on third down and
then
the second would be very similar in the
red zone where you get down into the red
zone and
you can play 11 on 11 football i do
believe that they should get carson once
off the field when jalen hurts gets on
because if they're going to bring jalen
hurts on the field and
still leave carson wentz on the field
you're playing 10 on 11.
i have long said that both those guys
should be in the backfield at the same
time that's when you can really get
creative that's when you can stress the
defense
they haven't done it yet this year i
don't know why because i think that's
been a failure but
um they need to play better carson needs
to be play play better
but jalen hurts will have his impact and
i think in situational football
dan appreciate the time like i said i'm
i i appreciate your work i hope this is
the first of many times you appear
on this show when you say when you see
green next tell him i said hi
um tell him that i i would feel his pain
um
but i never thought i would name my
children sam and dharma
darnold okay as he once told me um
hang in there just just got five more
games to go that's it five more to go
and then we get to the best news jets
fans had all year so i appreciate it's
an absolute honor man grew up watching
you so
any time it's a privilege i appreciate
that dan uh
nfl live with dan orlowski and the cast
of thousands later on on espn and for
eastern and then
monday night football tonight on the
worldwide leader in sports
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here